we have some incredible text messages
that have been leaked you may remember a
guy named mark meadows mark meadows was
donald trump's final chief of staff
lasting up through uh the end of trump's
presidency cnn has obtained
more than 2 000 about 2 300 in fact text
messages uh involving mark meadows and
what they expose is truly incredible
what we have learned and we're going to
look at some of these text messages
momentarily
they were brainstorming
how to lie about the trump riots how to
cover their you-know-whats
about the trump riots they were
coordinating a response that they knew
wasn't actually based in fact and we're
going to look at a couple of these text
messages these are fascinating
sean hannity the fox news propagandist
texted mark meadows and said is north
carolina going to be okay and mark
meadows said to hannity stress every
vote matters get out and vote on radio
and hannity responds
yes sir
quite literally fox propagandist taking
his marching orders from the chief of
staff of the president of the united
states we suspected it
but here we have the proof
sean hannity responded on it any
particular place we need to push and
meadows wrote back pennsylvania north
carolina arizona nevada
and hannity says got it everywhere
um there were some texts with uh matt
schlapp and mark meadows which aren't
super interesting
um
on november 6th just after the election
jason miller was putting out um talking
points
so that others could argue that
something's fishy and trump probably won
texting one other key data point in 2016
trump received 15.5 percent of the vote
in philly county today he's at 18.3
percent so he did better in that county
in 2016 philly county made up 11.3
percent of the total vote as it
currently stands philly county only
makes up 10.2 percent of the statewide
vote tally so
trump performed better in a smaller
share santorum was just making this
point on cnn cuts hard against the urban
vote stealing narrative okay so they're
coming up with these ideas to try to
support the claim false not based in
evidence that trump actually won
um
rick perry texted mark meadows we have
the data driven program that can clearly
show where the fraud was committed this
is the silver bullet pam bondi
misspelled has seen and agrees
all day every day just sending these
things back and forth back and forth
back and forth
ginny thomas the wife of supreme court
justice clarence thomas was texting mark
meadows
trying to understand the sydney powell
distancing
remember this was when the trump
campaign said oh sydney powell that
crazy lawyer she's on her own she's not
really with us and meadows wrote back
she doesn't have anything or at least
she won't share if she does to which
ginny thomas responds wow
wow
some other uh text messages that i want
to look at with you
donald trump jr texted mark meadows on
january 6th as the riots were taking
place and said he's got to condemn this
s asap the capital police tweet is not
enough
mark meadows writes back i'm pushing it
hard i agree
this his one you go to the mattresses on
they will try to f his entire legacy on
this if it gets worse
don jr
seemingly unable to talk sense into his
own father
was texting mark meadows saying the one
tweet isn't enough they're gonna screw
him
on
this mick mulvaney texted mark meadows
saying mark he needs to stop this now
can i do anything to help
republican congressman william timmons
tested texted the president needs to
stop this asap they all knew how bad
this was and they knew it was trumpists
and they knew it was bad for trump on
january 6.
rens priebus
texted mark meadows saying tell them to
go home
they all knew what it was and how bad it
looked they all knew it and yet publicly
they continued to spin a different line
and that night january 6 at night the
very fox hosts who were texting with
meadows and they all knew it was
trumpists they all knew trump wasn't
doing enough to stop it fact that he
instigated it
they went on fox and they said oh you
know it could have been antifa
could have been black lives matter who
knows what it was who it was so recently
democratic congressman jamie raskin said
he now is convinced that this was a
coordinated effort to cause these riots
and then to run interference he says
they have the evidence they have the
testimony and it's going to come out
and now we have the texts whether this
is all of it or part of it we don't yet
know
but the story republicans wove we knew
it was not accurate that's not a shock i
mean we're now what is it 15 months in
we knew that they weren't telling the
truth
but now we know that it was a
coordinated and knowing effort to
deceive not they just had the wrong
understanding of what happened it's
truly incredible
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night improves sleep
in many ways our sponsor chilly sleep
creates systems that cool down your bed
promoting deeper higher quality sleep it
also just feels great i use it at home
i'd recommend it to anyone and i've
recommended it to some friends who now
use it as well
chili sleeps product the uhler the cube
and the doc pro
they're all water-based temperature
controlled pads that fit onto your
existing mattress you can keep your bed
as low as 55 degrees as hot as 115
degrees i like 60 their new doc pro
sleep system has double the cooling
power of other models five times the
cooling contact whisper quiet you can
control it with your phone it's awesome
with chilly sleep there's no more
feeling hot at night no more sweating
cooling your bed down like this is
amazing you really have to try it for
yourself when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman you'll get 30 percent off of the
uhler and cube sleep systems and 10 off
the new dock pro this offer is only for
my audience the link is down below